aujourd'hui on va parler de qui de
quelle marque à votre avis je sais pas
je vous laisse deviner peut-être de aux
normes
on va parler aujourd'hui du honor play
[Musique]
deuxième jour à berlin on est parti pour
un événement énorme aujourd'hui on va
les rencontrer au nord au nord qui a
fait une présentation d'un tout nouveau
produit
j'ai hâte de voir alors même si
effectivement sur les réseaux sociaux ça
a déjà fuité
j'ai hâte de le voir parce que
franchement je pense que j'aurais plutôt
coup et là le corps c'est un petit peu
gâté à berlin le ciel
hier il faisait une chaleur énorme peu
trop d'ailleurs là on est pas mal un
petit peu à la fraîche à la cool le
temps de choper un but ce qui m'amène
jusqu'à 1 re s bahn baisse de métro
petrotrin et puis ensuite direct sur
l'effort il ya pas mal de choses à voir
alors j'ai aussi rencontré d'autres
personnes aujourd'hui je vais les
rencontrer des personnes de chez western
digital
je vais le faire un tour du côté de la
présentation sony espère avoir le temps
parce que l'événement de honor est à
l'autre bout de la vie enfin c'est un
micmac pas possible mais ça plutôt cool
et donc c'est parti on y va
à
[Musique]
retour à l'isf alors la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui est une vidéo qui est
proposé en partenariat avec le site
france france chopper je vous ai déjà
parlé c'est ainsi le français que permet
de trouver des produits high tech au
meilleur prix et pas que par exemple
vous voulez acheter un smartphone une
tablette un ordinateur quoi que ce soit
et vous voulez pas passer des heures à
chercher et c'est justement là
qu'intervient crossover fonctionnement
est super simple et repose pas du tout
sur les partenariats qui serait mis en
place par le site avec différentes
marques bien au contraire et c'est là
justement la force de crossover c'est sa
communauté faillir des gens comme vous
et comme moi qui vont aller faire des
recherches pour vous pour vous trouver
les meilleurs offres aux meilleurs prix
par exemple vous voulez acheter
l'honneur dix et franchement je le
comprends parce que c'est vraiment un
excellent smartphone ce que vous faites
si vous allez sur un site de e-commerce
en n'importe lequel vous recherchez la
fiche produit du aux nordistes vous
copier l'adresse web des ordis vous l'a
collé sur cros shopper et vous balancez
votre recherche très rapidement devait
recevoir les meilleures offres par mais
alors rassurez vous c'est pas du tout du
spal vous n'allez pas être du tout
embêté et vous pourrez faire meilleur
achat alors pris la peine de faire les
recherches par vous même faites le test
par vous même je vous ai mis le lien en
bas d'un description allez-y faites une
recherche son crossover vous allez voir
ça prend très très peu de temps et une
fois que vous aurez goûté vous fait plus
du tout vos achats de la même manière
sur internet aujourd'hui il est donc
pour un événement très particulier on va
parler de mon passé après on va parler
des odeurs alors on est là pour parler
du honor play on va regarder un petit
peu ce qui se passe qui coûtait de ce
nouveau smartphone de au nord on va
regarder mais sur les specs s'il est
bien aussi ça ça vous connaissez on va
faire un petit peu un tour voilà et puis
on testera un peu plus tard pour voir si
ce smartphone est bien comment ils
conditionnent par rapport à la
concurrence
est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter ou non mais
là ce que vous propose cette fois un
petit tour et barça directement
[Musique]
avant la présentation qui va commencer
d'ici quelques instants sans doute un
petit tour pour vous voyez un peu donc
là vous avez toute la salle de
conférence avec la cei qui est là
forcément ici écouter technique régime
maintenant la question c'est d'essayer
de trouver une petite place
vous avez les places de ventes sont des
places vip vous avez les honneurs frein
arrière et puis le reste du monde se
situent bien évident qu'elle
présentation qui nous a fait honneur
c'est complètement dingue parce que là
on se retrouve effectivement avec un
honneur play qui au final une nouvelle
série de smartphones dédiés aux gamers
qu'une annonce complètement dingue à la
fin honor va créer un espèce de haut
pour finepix dairin modèle hyper haut de
gamme c'est le magic 2 mais ça je vous
en parle juste après
bi
on aura fait une présentation juste
waouh sonore plaît c'est une nouvelle
série c'est un tout nouveau smartphone
qui va arriver vous avez la série view
avec le view disque qui arrivent en
début d'année vous avez la série un peu
plus classique avec les numéros au nord
8 en or 9 en or 10 et maintenant vous
avez est la série plaît qu'une série qui
est très clairement destiné aux gamers
au nord le martel et la firme c'est une
marque destinée pour les jeunes alors
les jeunes c'est pas forcément les 12 15
18 ans on est jeune même à 35 40 ans
donc c'est une marque qui est destiné
aux jeunes et qui sort vraiment un
produit qui est super et un tarif
défiant toute concurrence mais ça je
vais développer juste après le o nord
playes le honneur plaît c'est un produit
vraiment optimisé pour les gamers avec
le gpu turbo avec un kirin 970 avec des
vibrations directement dans votre
smartphone lorsque vous allez jouer ils
ont un partenariat avec pbg lorsque vous
allez jouer à des jeux typés ubg ou
autre dès lors que vous allez jouer peu
importe votre smartphone mais vibrer en
fonction de l'action vous allez voir des
intensités différentes
ça permet d'être complètement immerge
dans le jeu et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est toc un smartphone qui a un
écran de 6 3 pouces qui occupent 89% de
la face avant vous avez la petite
encoche sur le haut mais qui peut être
complètement annulé de façon logicielle
vous choisissez vous la mettez vous la
mettez pas dans les paramètres faites ce
que vous voulez côté design vous avez
une petite barbe noire en bas ça le
petit menton monde dépend des
contraintes techniques et un smartphone
pas cher forcément il est là mais c'est
pas du tout gênant un dos en métal qui
donne un aspect assez sympa quand vous
avez deux types de modèles vous avez les
modèles avec les couleurs le bleu
noir l'ultraviolet et vous avez les
modèles meilleur edition vous avez la
player edition raid qui est super beau
avec un design très particulier à
l'arrière et puis là playoffs edition
black qui est aussi très sympa un
smartphone qui équipe est forcément du
gpu turbo sépulture bon on a parlé ya pa
très très longtemps ensemble sur le aux
nordistes ils arrivent sur celui là il
sera aussi mis à jour sur plein d'autres
smartphones e mail graphique homs hama
vous pouvez tout voir c'est vrai que
c'est bien elle est plutôt bon confirme
vraiment beaucoup plus de puissance et
surtout des économies d'énergie si vous
n'aviez pas le cpu turbo par rapport aux
modèles avec le gpu turbo vous avez un
gain de 60 % de puissance en plus si on
regarde un peu lors de diverses marques
on voit que selon au nord il serait plus
puissant plus performant que le samsung
galaxy s 9 plus nous annonce 4 6 heures
de jeu sur les honneurs play contre 4
heures sur le samsung galaxy s 9 plus
cette mise à jour permet à la batterie
de tenir beaucoup plus longtemps c'est
une vraie optimisation logiciel qui vous
permet d'économiser 30% de batterie
notez que vous avez une batterie de 3750
millions terreur qui vous permet selon
noor l'utiliser pendant un jour et demi
en utilisation un peu hardcore vous avez
la cat des stocks vibe la chaîne sont
vraiment les vibrations quatre
dimensions votre smartphone devient une
manette et vivre en fonction du jour à
savoir vous avez plus de 30 scénarios
différents dont bon franchement vous
avez de quoi faire vous avez également
sont plus immersif un son en trois
dimensions alors c'est du son stéréo
il est spécialisé avec un effet trois
dimensions qui vous permet toujours
d'avoir une expérience de jeu beaucoup
plus confortable beaucoup plus sympas et
des toujours plus immersive pour moi que
c'est vraiment la donne de ce produit
sont en place c'est vraiment d'avoir un
produit puissant avec un kirin 970 avait
déjà la faire là il ya le peering 980
qui va être officialisé demain pas c'est
à dire aujourd'hui moment je publie la
vidéo avec le green à 170 vous pouvez
déjà franchement voir venir il est
couplé à 4 gigas de ram vous avez le gpu
turbo qui nous donne plus de puissance
vous permet d'économiser toujours plus
votre batterie
les vibrations de la manette les
vibrations du smartphone se trompe en
direction de la mecque les vibrations du
smartphone et avec un son spatialisé
vous avez tout pour avoir une expérience
de
ce qui est extraordinaire en plus de ça
alors c'est pas forcément vous
intéresser mais au nord a fait un
partenariat avec audi sport pour
vraiment aller dans l'idée de la
puissance dans l'idée du sport mécanique
un partenariat qui permet vraiment de
renforcer l'image de ce smartphone comme
étant un produit dédié à la vitesse donc
en cas d'un smartphone au gaming
forcément qu'on va pas mettre des roues
un smartphone n'a pas à aller faire les
magasins du moins au niveau des caméras
vous avalerez hier une double caméra de
16 mégapixels et j'ai pas d'info sur
l'ouverture pour le moment le spartak on
va les tester un très très bientôt donc
vous invite à faire une chose cela
rester connectés et à vous abonner comme
ça vous aurez beaucoup plus d'infos vous
êtes toujours l'intelligence
artificielle qui est mis en avant par au
nord vous avez 22 reconnaissance de
scène vous avez le port traitement vous
avez un stabilisateur alors j'ai testé
la stabilisation déjà et que gpu turbo
sur le ordi c'est franchement bluffant
surtout si vous avez l'habitude de mes
vidéos voit tout de suite que dès que ça
bouge un peu
absolument pas là ça bouge pas d'un iota
c'est franchement génial et là avec le
au nord à hiesse vous allez avoir
quelque chose d'hyper stabiliser pour
vos photos et pour vos vidéos c'est
aussi un point qui était mis en avant
par au nord c'est à dire prendre vos
smartphones faire des photos en faible
luminosité
là où il faudrait normalement un trépied
pour vraiment pas avoir du tout d'image
qui bouge au niveau de la lumière là ça
va être complètement calibré grâce au
nord-est grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle et grâce au gpu turbo se
permettra d'avoir un rang du top et de
pouvoir faire des photos tableaux dit et
dans toutes les conditions
ça s'est vraiment bien à l'avant vous
avez également une caméra de 16
mégapixels pour cette fille avec une
reconnaissance en 3d de votre visage
vous avez bien évidemment les faits
évoqués le 3d portrait lightning avec
différents modes pour avoir un effet
trop nice même si très très sympa il
tourne sous android etc la surcouche em
8 points 2 vous avez bien évidemment le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
située tout
et c'est un produit qui est disponible
dès aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui donc
s'appliquer déjà disponible en version 4
gigas 64 joueurs de stockage à 329 euros
et vous trouvez en player edition avec
un dock est juste magnifique 4 gigas de
ram 64 giga de stockage à 349 euros
un produit qui est dispo chez amazon
cdiscount enfin si vous intéresse vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans description à
mon avis connaissons la qualité de honor
connaissant leur travail alain destée
beaucoup de smartphones de honor et
dernièrement le aux nordistes avec le
gpu turbo je crois que c'est au nord
plaît il va être vraiment une petite
bombe et si vous intéresse à mon avis
pour y aller les yeux fermés
[Musique]
la deuxième annonce à café au nord c'est
un produit d'exception
c'est vraiment le produit d'exception en
2007 ils ont sorti le aux normes hadji
qu'ils sont libres pourquoi pas au final
réitérer et sortir le honor magic 2
c'est incroyable quand j'ai vu la photo
à paris
je me suis dit mais serait c'est pas le
haut norman dicks élu au poste fixe
c'est à dire que vous avez votre
smartphone avec la petite partie qui va
se lever pour vous sortir la partie
caméra un smartphone avec un écran
vraiment bord à bord de tous les côtés
il n'y a absolument pas de notre chat
aux parents cochent pas de menton en bas
pas de bord sur les côtés c'est un vrai
écran en face avant avec votre parti qui
sort sur le haut pour avoir votre module
appareil photo à l'avant et à l'arrière
exactement comme sur le peaufine du
chaland c'est un produit qui pour
l'instant n'est pas disponible
barrick et présentez nous ont un peu mis
l'eau à la bouche en le montrant
directement lors la présentation et
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est un
produit qui va être hyper attendu parce
que le profane dit que c'est forcément
un produit assez cher on imagine que le
magic 2 naji tout aura aussi un tarif
assez élevé on imagine que ce produit
sera pas forcément à 350 euros qui se
montre un peu plus cher mais connaissant
la politique tarifaire de honor à mon
avis il devrait être extrêmement bien
placé au niveau tarif donc ça devrait
être une petite bombe atomique
en plus si loin la magic charge peut on
en reparlera plus tard vous avez par le
regard plein plein de choses dessus et
il tournera avec le kirin 980 ce qui a
je serai absolument pas la fête donc
tout ça vous invite à faire une chose ça
restait qualité à vous abonner parce que
on va parler du nord plaît et on va le
tester d'ici quelques jours on va bien
évidemment parler du magic 2d qui sera
annoncée dès qui sera officielle comme
ça on va pouvoir aller voir un petit
plus qu'avant
et puis on le comparera par rapport à
l'euro phénix parce que je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant en tout cas ce que
nous a faits au nord ici c'est une vraie
démonstration de force et ça c'est
vraiment génial vous avez tous les
produits qui sont est derrière vous
pouvez le tester avec pib j'ai honoré
actuellement la 4e marque en france la
première en chine et va vraiment à mon
sens prendre des positions gagnées ni
par marchand les années à venir parce
que ils ont une position tarifaire qui
est extraordinaire les produits sont
d'une excellente qualité toujours plus
attractifs toujours plus intéressant
c'est fun c'est jeune femme dresse pas
uniquement aux jeunes s'adresse à des
personnes qui sont exigeantes qui
veulent de la qualité à moindre coût et
ça c'est vraiment toi
on va tester jeu google assistant suit
avec max voilà donc on va attendre notre
heure tout est là le problème c'est que
signifie qu'il faut parler en allemand
ok google je ne parle pas un mot
d'allemand tu parles allemande a jamais
ça va être compliqué google et bing ein
berliner
[Musique]
de chaque côté google buzz on l'espère
stadium
qui mieux mieux berliner
[Musique]
me voici donc la suisse tonnes je sais
pas trop ce que c'est ça tu sais c'est
pour retrouver tes clés ah ok croyez que
la veille il avait gagné 1 google
assistants n'ont même pas génial tu as
vu tu vraiment être voix il a reconnu la
pac satellite
c'est la seule franchise je sais dit
rice bin ein berliner et il se lève et
dise c'est tout ce que je sais dire
suffit ça je m'en fous
guten tag
[Musique]